okay I think we're up now
then
cool this must be the most ridiculously
prepared I have ever been been for one
of these impromptu live streams this
might actually be the most prepared I
have been for a live stream in general I
I literally have just been sitting
around for like the past 10 minutes
waiting to push the start streaming
button
so uh Welcome Friends um so this is a
December live stream I uh got a lot out
of the live stream that I did back in
November so I thought we'd do it again
and it turned out that
um this this Friday was really the only
Friday of the month that was going to
work cuz um I didn't want to try and
catch people uh right after Christmas
and I have plans next
Friday so uh I figured I would do
another live stream and uh as you might
be able to tell from the sound of my
voice I've been kind of sick this week
so I wasn't sure if I was going to be
able to um to do a live stream this week
and it just so happens that uh it worked
out so
hooray um so if y'all are watching out
there please chime off in the chat let
me know that you're
there say hi and let me know where
you're
from
yay it's uh good to have you all joining
me here I've I've I've got my tea to
help out with my voice here
tonight it's delicious so
um I like to drink this concoction that
um uh dizzy says hi hi dizzy so there's
this concoction that I that I really
like to drink um that we used to call it
tea and Tang when I was growing up uh
and it turns out that it's a recipe for
something called Uh Russian friendship
tea where you mix together um you know
your your your standard like uh your
your standard tea and uh
you mix it up with something with with
some Citrus flavors so stuff that like
is orange flavored lemon flavored things
like that so it's tea but it has a nice
little uh it has a nice little citrusy
Tang to it so it's kind of sweet in
addition to the bitter I'm a big fan
Kevin logger says hi there drexx from
Eastern Oregon hello there Kevin
Meredith Clan is joining us from Norfolk
in the UK welcome Meredith glad to have
you here um so yeah this is a live Q&A
so the purpose here for the next hour is
that yall can ask me any questions that
you have whether there is a PO trick
that you
are um that you're struggling with or I
just put out an interesting video about
flowarts culture if uh folks have
watched that and and have further
questions for me based upon that or
anything else that comes to mind I'll
let you know if it's something I don't
feel comfortable answering but uh yeah
this is y'all's time for the next hour
um
and of course as it says down along the
bottom of the screen um if you want to
help out the channel uh there's that
little button that looks like uh a
dollar with like the square around it
and everything uh if you click on that
you can send the channel a tip uh all
that money comes straight to me so it's
a great way of supporting the channel
and showing appreciation um and as tends
to happen uh doing these live streams
here um
sometimes the question cue gets a little
bit deep and so if you send me uh a
super chat I will bump your question to
the top of the queue as I'm as I'm
looking through them so little little
incentive for helping me out so yeah
thanks in advance friends Charlie frier
3D says hello Drex love your stuff bro
appreciate it thank you Charlie yeah
how's everybody doing out there tonight
it is pretty cold where I am I don't
know uh I would imagine that that
Eastern Oregon and and UK are both
pretty cold as well right
now but I could be
wrong anyways um send me those questions
friends send me those questions uh let
me know what you got on your minds this
evening and uh what I can help you out
with Kevin logger says cold and wet that
sounds about right we had a so it warmed
up for just a couple days here in DC
this past week problem was
uh it rained cats and dogs every single
day that it was warm out woke up one
morning and it was fog that turned into
rain which really sucked cuz I was so
looking forward to going outside and
like flowing in decent weather there was
a 60° day here um 60
fahrenheit and uh it was really
disappointing that that I I couldn't go
out that day because it was it was very
very
rainy um this is delicious yeah
definitely look up a recipe for Russian
friendship
tea online and uh and and try this out
for yourself because it is it is
delightful uh i i i a big fan Uh Kevin
says having a lot of freezing fog in
Oregon I believe
it I believe it yeah I I have a student
who lives in well I have a student who
um kind
of she was doing private lessons with me
for a while but she didn't have a good
space to do it indoors and a couple
weeks ago we basically had to stop doing
her lessons for the winter because
um because the space outside was just
getting to be too cold she she couldn't
keep on doing it so I I imagine uh
Oregon's weather must be uh a shade or
two colder even than that good times
good
times um so yeah maybe uh maybe while
we're wait while I'm waiting for you all
to come up with some questions to ask me
perhaps I could ask you some questions
um oh never mind one just came through
from Charlie frier any tips on how I
could get better at pois spinning um I
would ask in in what aspect um what
aspect of pois spinning are you trying
to get better at CU there's a whole
bunch of different ways you can do that
you can broaden the vocabulary of tricks
that uh that you're working on you can
work on transition and movement you can
work on Flow
um yeah even you can work on like oh I
want to develop uh a a more
comprehensive framework for
understanding poy Trix so there there's
there's a lot of potential areas where
you could improve in so if if you let me
know which one you are most interested
in that will help me narrow things
down uh and the answer is movement
um as in dance I would assume question
mark I promise I'm not just like you
know trying to uh trying to Juke my my
statistics for the the chat here I I
genuinely am just like trying to narrow
things down yes interested in dance okay
cool
um well my friend you've come to the
right place so let
me let me switch over to full body stuff
here
so how to improve on movement um I think
the the the kind of number one thing to
do is
um so I I don't know if you have much of
a background in dance or movement but uh
assuming that you don't I think some of
the biggest things to get started on
would be number one just like working on
being able to move to the beat of the
music and you can start off with like
really simple stuff like if you're
listening to a song you just like snap
your fingers on the like
ones and then the ones and
threes and then every
beat to get used to moving your body in
tandem with the music once you got that
down and you're able to like kind of uh
feel that a little bit you can start to
work on things like footwork like you
can just start with a two-step in so
think that you want to step out with the
right back with the right out with the
right back with the right and you can
either do this by like tapping your toes
as you go out or you could tap your heel
as you go out uh you could step forward
as you're doing
this you could step to the
side you can step
back I almost did it wrong
there and the the idea here is just
you're starting to get yourself used to
moving to a beat um from there I would
say that it's a good idea to start
working
on um I guess volume so one of these
things that always kind of drives me
nuts about how we teach people pois
spinning is that we start off in a place
where we teach people to take up as
little volume as possible so what you
want to do then is you want to
experiment with seeing how much volume
you can take up as you're spinning so
for example rather than like doing a
waist strap that just goes straight back
and forth like this B ring you can
instead take some lunges from side to
side and look just how much more
interesting that made that waist strap
going back and forth and the reason is
is because it's registering not just in
the POI but also in my
body um likewise you can play around
with say like the different difference
between a standard windmill or like
opening up into a big windmill this kind
of p truvian man style thing and this
also takes us into uh another area that
is also very helpful to work with which
you know once again the default way we
teach people to spin POI we're kind of
keeping our hands even with the bottom
of our rib cage as we're doing our like
you know weaves and butterflies and all
that um and it's also important to play
around with levels getting down low and
up high so one thing I really love doing
with my windmills is playing around with
uh over curves and under curves where
I'm moving my butt through the air
you'll notice I am not bending over as
I'm going down I'm keeping my body
pointed straight upright even as my hips
are moving around this is entirely about
moving my booty not about my upper body
uh the way you do this is uh you stand
in place
with your feet about shoulders width
apart and you start off by just bending
one knee out to the side so I start by
bending my right knee and do you see how
it lowered my level a little bit and
also moved my butt over to the side from
here I bend my left knee so my booty is
uh kind of further down and then I
extend my right leg so that my booty is
over to the left and then I extend my
left leg so again bend the right bend
the left straighten out the the right
straighten out the left and if you do
this in a smooth continuous fashion you
wind up creating this curve that your
hips move through in space and you can
use this with so many different py
tricks like it's great for uh your
povian man windmills it's also fantastic
for tuck
turns heck you can also do this with
some Techo moves too so like if you're
moving around your hands and together
same with uh pendulum versus trra like
this this is also a good fit for it so
playing around with volume like
um very specifically start making
different choices in terms of how much
space you're taking up with your petrix
whether it be
taking your waist straps further from
side to side with these
lunges uh or perhaps you're taking your
butterflies and boom playing around with
doing a big butterfly every couple beats
even just with a standard three beat
weave you can play around with opening
spaces on the x- Axis or opening spaces
on the Y AIS or even opening the spaces
entirely making the weave seem really
big and that way you can go back and
forth between places where it's really
small and very big and play around with
Dynamics there um so volume levels and
the final thing I would suggest playing
around with is just moving around as
you're spinning poi um an exercise I
love to give people is something that I
call an advanced reel wherein you know
of course we all learn our basic reels
where we're turning back and forth
between the pois spinning forwards and
uh sorry that was a tuck turn and
reverse on our sides in wheel plane so
what I love to give people is um going
from Wheel plane
to wall plane to wheel plane to wall
plane and then wheel plane again so
you're actually stopping in every single
planer orientation right and once you
have like drilled this in all four
timing and Direction modes um you can
start to play around with stepping
around on stage and you can be able to
keep the Poise spinning in that timing
and Direction mode regardless of which
way you're facing or what part of the
stage you happen to be in this will help
you get down freedom of movement a lot
more and that will be super helpful for
getting down uh your dance stuff I would
also recommend um just looking up
dancers on Instagram and and getting
inspiration from them um another thing I
love doing is playing around with the
articulation of the feet because again
playing around with waist straps like
this so boring but if say I were to take
some inspiration from uh modern dance or
ballet and add like a POS to each side
here where I'm touching uh the foot of
the working leg uh up next to the knee
of the standing leg I wind up in a place
where
boom all of a sudden that looks a lot
more interesting again now doesn't it so
play around with those articulations you
can do Coupe where you bring one foot
next to the other leg's
ankle you can play around with POS where
you bring it next to the knee you can
play around with tandu where you're just
darting your toe
out if you're want to get really Saucy
with it you could do like a botma
kicking out to either side when you
switch which side you're on there's so
many options there
um personally I think that it's a good
idea when you're spinning and you do a
transition that the transition should
register through your body like your
body has a response to it so say like
taking a big old windmill like this and
then when I do a pendulum to switch up
do you see how I took that pendulum
through my entire body it's not just uh
and I've switched it is huh my body had
a my entire body had a response to it so
those are a few ways that I think um you
could work to improve your
movement um get down the basics of just
moving to music um get down your two
steps play around with volume play
around with levels uh work on your
Advanced reels so that you're able to
explore the stage freely and keep your
timing and Direction consistent in your
planes um and also to play around with
the articulations of your feet and legs
and see if you can't work in such a
fashion that when you do transitions
uh your entire body has response to them
those are some options that I would
suggest that turned into a much longer
answer perhaps than people were
anticipating but hey I'm here for
it
h me switch back and see how we're doing
over
here
um Charlie fer says The Dance Part I got
I have a dance background okay cool also
saying very helpful thank you Drex
you're welcome you're welcome I'm glad
that was helpful sorry I didn't realize
that you already had a dance background
so um some some of that might have been
me explaining stuff that you already
know how to do but hopefully uh
hopefully still helpful hopefully still
helpful and I will also say that I I
think one of the most underrated tools
that we have as pois Spinners
is when we execute stalls uh they can be
very percussive
I love seeing stalls used on a beat to
kind of accentuate the beat um and I
think unfortunately we we too often
think of stalls as simply being a means
to an end rather than being kind of like
ornamentation and and of themselves so
that's another thing I would I would
recommend checking out uh Meredith Clan
says have watch your tutorial on nebil
so many times have broken it down but
still struggling to make it work any
tips please um
yes conceivably uh can you give me some
some details on where you're getting
stuck um it'll help me narrow it down
because otherwise I'm just going to do a
lesson on how to do the nasol from
scratch well and maybe that's what
you're looking for but uh I can be of
more help to you if you narrow down
where you're getting stuck um Carrie
Fitzgerald hey Carrie uh Carrie says H
Drex thanks for your work sharing the
love of Po I'm curious about how you
choose your
music is it what grabs you is it
dependent on what's available to use on
Instagram or other platforms so it
depends on what the purpose is
um so
Carrie is um Carrie's one of the
wonderful folks in my live stream dance
classes that happen on Tuesday
evenings and
um as Carrie knows one of the things
that I love doing as part of class is
writing uh sections of Coro to to teach
to the class and in some cases I'll take
um I'll take
uh requests from the class for songs
that they want to perform to uh Carrie
says the live stream classes are amazing
by the way highly recommend oh thanks
Carrie I appreciate that yeah y'all
should uh should check that out I will I
will
drop the URL in here to the classes so
yall can sign up because I'd love to
have you
T anyway um so in the case of when I'm
going to choreograph something for class
what I'm looking for is um really what
I'm looking for is a story I'm looking
for Dynamics I'm looking for a song
where it starts with one feel and then
we arrive someplace else in the course
of it because I really like playing with
Dynamics in dance uh whether Dynamics in
like speed or volume or what have you um
so that's what I look for for the class
choreo and sometimes y all introduce me
to songs that I absolutely love I
choreographed a full piece to uh lose
control by Teddy swims this past year
thanks to the recommendation of somebody
in class um and I I don't know if I
would have discovered that song
otherwise um it's funny too cuz I didn't
know it was in the top 40 and then like
I started pulling up the top 40 on Apple
music I'm like oh there's a bunch of
bangers in here
um so I want up discovering a bunch of
cool music that
way um it's interesting you ask me that
question right now
because I've actually been in the middle
of like a top secret project which is
um I decided as like an an exercise to
write 30 seconds of choreography for 30
days I am as of now 6 days away from the
end of that so I've written 30 seconds
worth of
choreography um
for 24 solid days now and it
interestingly enough one of the biggest
challenges there has been to pull out
pieces of music that I want to I want to
dance to sometimes it stuff that I find
in Instagram's recommended
feed that um you know I I just discover
something new that that that like gets
that that gets me moving
um several times in the course of the
past 24 days it's actually a song that I
I've been listening to for quite some
time sometimes for
years and I will just have in my mind um
here here is really the answer to your
question question Carrie here's the real
answer to your question um it's when I
listen to music I can see in my head
movement that goes to it pretty
much every single thing that I've
choreographed more or less there there
have been some exceptions but most of
the stuff that I've choreographed what
comes out of me is I will listen to the
music and I can I can see a picture in
my head I can see I can see movement
that goes with the parts of the song I
can see a trick that goes with a
particular line in the song or like the
beat has a particular feel and I'm just
kind of like oh like you know yesterday
the um the uh song that I did my
choreography to was
um Alejandro by uh Lady Gaga which I
mean that that song's like 15 years old
now but it's always stuck around in my
head because I remember remember in my
dance classes back in the day we would
do a little exercise where we we where
we would prance essentially we would do
these like little walks around where we
had to freeze with the
um uh with the working leg and
Coupe and I just remember that song
coming up and being like oh man this
would be the perfect song for that
exercise cuz
the um that kind of like very floating
uh but still percussive line is
something that um it just it instantly
conjured to mind that that prancing
exercise and so that that was that was
how I started off that bit of
choreography just cuz I I've literally
seen that in my head for 15 years
so
um yeah that that that's the big one and
and I have to say that like um
a lot of stuff that pops up like you
know sometimes there's a song that has a
lyric I really love sometimes it's got a
beat that I really love sometimes it's
got a really funky Baseline but always
what it is is there will be a song that
I listen to and it just makes me want to
move and I can see in my head the way I
want to move to it um that is that is
the
very nebulous and and and kind of UN
unsatisfying answer to that question I'm
afraid but hopefully hopefully there's
something of value in
that um I'm falling behind again oh and
once again reminder uh if you send a
super chat I will bump your question to
the top of the queue and the Super Chat
uh comes directly to me YouTube doesn't
keep any of it so it's a great way to
support the channel uh groovy gang says
what key advice could you give to
someone learning spiral WS with po
you're amazing and have helped me so
much my flow Journey um again it's
helpful to know where you're getting
stuck but I can give you just kind of
General
tips so um 90% of the time when I see
somebody struggling with spiral wraps it
is for this reason it is that their poy
are not as straight in um in wall plane
as they would like it to be so you have
this thing happen where the POI kind of
fall off your hands or sometimes they do
the thing where they're trying to chase
the poy outward as they're as they're
doing the spiral wrap um and what this
is is you kind of there's two parts to
this because the first is that um you
have to either compensate for the planes
not being straight uh or you have to
train yourself to get the planes a
little bit more straight so for example
if you're finding that the POI are
falling off your fingers uh swinging
over towards your right then what you
need to do is actually like angle your
hands back to the left um to try and
make sure that you're compensating for
what's going on in the uh uh in the
planes being
off the other thing that you're going to
want to do is um I would honestly
practice a bunch with what I call the
lanes of poi where you get used to
having the PO kind of flush with your
body like this and leaving your left
hand just a little bit further away from
your body than your right hand um but
keeping them parallel here the reason
being that in a lot of cases what's
happening is people are like a little
uncomfortable with having the pois so
close to them and so the further they
reach away guess what that's when that
that's that's when the planes get a
little bit off so get comfortable
keeping your planes close it will help
you out um and once you do uh notice
those places where the poer kind of
falling off your hands and compensate
Point your fingers in the opposite
direction so again if they're falling
off to the right you point your fingers
back to the left to compensate for it
and eventually you should be able to get
to the point where you can keep your
planes uh straight up in wall plane as
you're doing this the other thing I see
sometimes happens with people is they
get stuck in the place where the the poy
wrap up and they they kind of have a
hard time getting back out of it the
timing on that one is always a little
trick trick because you basically have
to get good at seeing that moment like a
half a second after the poy complete
wrapping around your hand and you like
anticipate this a little bit by moving
your hands around with the POI and then
what you want to do is real quickly snap
your wrists back the other way so do you
see how um in that moment right before
the wrap completes I'm kind of twisting
my wrists in the direction that the PO
are wrapping that puts me in a place
where there's like some elastic tension
both in my wrists as well as the POI and
that way I can just snap my wrists back
and that brings the poy right back out
of there um which of course Works to
great effect as a uh suspension tool for
I think it's Charlie frier is the one
who out there who has Dance Experience
so this is one of those things I love to
do as like a finishing move in my
choreography is to bring it to a stop
with a spiral wrap because it's
sometimes a surprising to people when
the PO just like come to a dead stop
like that uh especially if theyve seen
other people doing spiral WS they're
going to expect that they're going to
come right back out and being able to
just stop on a dime there is something I
really
appreciate so uh I hope there's
something in there that's helpful to
you let me know if you have a more
specific
question all righty then uh Charlie
frier Charlie frier III I was reading
that as Charlie frier
3D oh hooray Carrie thank you so much
for the uh thank you for the Super Chat
I really appreciate you thank you so
much um yeah if you have a question
throw that in there I will bump it to
the top of the queue U and it has a
little avoc I think no it's a pair a
pair saying thank you for being you a I
appreciate that Carrie thank you for
being you and for supporting the channel
it is much
appreciated
um let me see here uh Charlie frier III
not 3D is asking uh any tips for editing
effects on PO to make the movements much
more cooler like in your videos um oh
and Carri is saying thanks Drex
interesting that the music seems to be
very visual for you it is definitely
um okay so if you're asking how I get
the effects that I use in my videos I I
did a video two years ago outlining what
the technique is um the long and short
of it is is that
um you really
need you need three things really to to
to do those effects um the first thing
you need is uh good lighting and
sometimes you can achieve this uh out in
the wild and sometimes it's just more
helpful to do a controlled environment
where you can control the lighting and
how bright it
is um but basically you need lighting
that like the ambient light is just a
little bit dimmer than the POI
themselves usually I do this at Sunset
and it is it is so it is such a pain in
the butt to shoot these videos on
location because I'm basically waiting
for this just little 10minute window of
time around it's usually it usually
comes like 10 to 20 minutes after uh
after Sunset where the ambient there
there's like enough ambient light that
like the camera can still see me but
that um the but the ambient light is
dimmer than the poy is the reason being
that um I'm going to need to do some VFX
on that
later so second thing you need is you
need a really good camera um
specifically you need a camera that is
going to allow you to
edit um at least two if not three
different settings those three settings
are uh number one you need to be able to
control the shutter
speed number two you need to be able to
control the iso uh the the the uh
exposure of the shot and finally it's
really helpful to be able to control um
the frame rate now I also very
frequently will change aperture settings
on on the camera but it's it's not
strictly necessary that's just me like
doing fine
tuning so what you want to do is you
want to set up your video such
that it's actually a little bit
underexposed it's it's a little darker
than you want cuz
what you're going to do there is
um here is a cool inspirational video of
Alejandro says Kevin interesting
um
so uh oh yeah I was talking about
shooting so you want to underexpose it
just a hair um you want your body to
still be like a little bit visible but
not hugely so
um generally speaking the settings that
I aim for are um I want the iso to be
lower than
500 I want the shutter speed to be uh 1
over
60 uh and I want the frame rate to be 60
frames a second so you'll
note the frame rate and the shutter
speed are equivalent to each other um
most people who have like learned uh how
to create video and and like work with
cameras the traditional way uh will be a
gas that I'm suggesting doing this
because um generally
speaking it's recommended that you do
something called the
180° uh rule which is your shutter speed
is 1/2 your frame rate so if you're
shooting at 30 frames a second you wind
up with a shutter speed of 1 over
60 in my case I want the shutter speed
to be equivalent to
um the frame rate and I shoot at 60
frames a second specifically for that
reason so I can simulate the
appearance of using the 180° shutter
rule even though I'm
not so I shoot my slightly
underdeveloped um video and then I bring
it home and I edit it and this is where
the magic happens so basically what I'll
do is I'll take the take that I want to
hold on to and I'll make a copy of it so
I'm going to create like two different
layers the the base layer is just the
video by itself nothing's
changed but the other layer which is
going to be the top layer I apply what's
called a Luma key to it
um and most video editing programs that
are worth their salt will have a Luma
key or some equivalent to it I believe
it's called extract in uh Adobe Premiere
and once you apply that you you're going
to have to adjust the tolerance and what
you should see happen there is
absolutely everything in the frame
except for the light which includes the
POI is going to disappear everything
else becomes
transparent once that's done you you
apply a plug-in um in Premiere it's
called
Echo and in Final Cut it is called
trails and that is the tool that you use
to actually add the trails but here's
the key because you're only doing it on
the layer that you applied that Luma key
to the trails are only being applied to
the
LEDs this is what you
want you do all of this editing in a in
a project that is 60 frames a second so
it matches the settings that you
recorded the video
at and then once you have all these
pieces in place um I also generally to
then
um I I've changed the way that I do this
since I made that video and I should
probably make another video
there there is actually one change that
I make to the base layer the the the
layer where
um which is just the the the basic video
it's not the uh it's it's not the trails
and that's that um I go ahead and uh
adjust the color curves like I go ahead
and and do some color grading work here
and specifically um I
oh Dan
thank you
Dan it's not showing me your last name
sorry uh yikes still waiting for the PO
I ordered a couple weeks ago uh I'm
sorry to hear that uh you didn't order
them from me though because I don't sell
poy
um I'm curious who you did order them
from though uh if you got a question
about that you feel free to ask it and I
will bump it to the top of the queue
here but thank you so much for the Super
Chat I really appreciate it thank you
for supporting the
Channel all right I'm going to wrap it
up here not the least of which because
uh my my voice is starting to get a
little bit ragged here
um
so yeah um okay so what I'll do is I'll
go into the Luma curves that is just the
light curves and I'll basically just
like take a section of the mid-range and
like pull it out to make the entire uh
kind of base layer uh of the video
brighter and so that makes it look like
it was recorded in full daylight and so
then I export that video at 60 frames a
second and I create a new project that
is only 24 frames a
second and I import back in that video
that I just exported so it displays a 24
frames a second but it has the qualities
of a and I I still get my unbroken
Trails but it has the qualities of a
video that was shot um with a shredder
speed of of 1 over 60 so it looks like I
was using the 360° rule the 180° rule
even though I wasn't and that is how we
get the videos that I post on my Channel
with those special effects attached to
them that was a long story I probably
should have just made an instructional
video about that but hopefully that
helps uh I hope you're taking notes now
um let's see here um rocket Roy says I
am a fan of video editing oh goodness
another one from Dan not complaining it
was the link you recommended I'm in the
states and didn't realize this was
overseas until after ordering not your
fault just letting you know for future
recommendations ah I got you well so
first and foremost thank you for the
other Super Chat thank you for both
super chats that's really sweet of you
um so um I think I know who you're
ordering from my uh let me guess it's
it's neop poy you were getting some sock
poy yeah so
the I I I have also I I will freely
admit I've encountered some problems
with uh their POI coming through customs
myself um I've had it take as little as
12 days I've had it take as much as like
a couple months um so yeah
that I I I feel your pain there I I have
talked with the company I I'm trying to
convince them to set up a us-based
distributor so that this doesn't happen
and they just like send a whole big
shipment of poy to somebody living in
the United States who then sends it to
other people living in the United States
but yeah it's really annoying I'm sorry
you're dealing with that right now
you're not the only person I've heard of
who's had who's who's who's had that
that challenge um and
unfortunately I wish I could tell you
when it's going to come through but like
yeah Customs is is really weird in that
regard um and it
just from what I can tell there there's
no solid estimate there
and yeah that's definitely a bummer it's
definitely a bummer that it can
sometimes take so long and you you're
right I when I'm promoting that company
I should indeed mention that shipping
can be a pain you are you are absolutely
right to give me that
note
um me jump back here oh uh rocket Roy
I'm a fan of video editing based on the
beat intricacies of a song yep I I am
too picking the right song for the
project can be the longest process of
the project can relate yeah well and and
it's also like really fun when I find a
song that like as I'm listening to it
I'm just like hey I am so utterly
motivated to
like I'm going to have to listen to this
song hundreds of times both as I'm
choreographing to it and as I'm editing
to it and I am so down for that I those
songs are very very rare I've found only
a small handful of them over the years
but when I do find them I really
appreciate
them um Charlie frier I thir says by
effects I mean like as you spin your PO
there's visible Trail patterns such as
if it's magic uh did I answer that
question oh yeah you you did say in here
um thanks so much that helps a lot keep
up the lessons you're appreciated I
learned so much from watching your
tutorials you're welcome groovy gang
Kevin
logger that I don't think that link ever
came
through um okay so Charlie frier did get
the information he was hoping for uh on
how
to edit
um edit videos with
Trails um Dan Campbell says neop po yes
and sounds good awesome I'm glad I'm I'm
glad that that is as helpful as it can
be yeah it's again it they need a US
space distributor just straight up I
I this has been this is a conversation
I've had with them before and you're now
the second person to bring this up in in
the past week so um I will definitely
make it a priority to have that
conversation with them again uh before
the end of the year
um Mula inara will you ever host a
giveaway Ultra po or po or flow PO is
new Coral poy um
[Applause]
sorry
there there's a story for at least part
of that so I will I will say that it is
highly unlikely that uh I will do a
Coral poy giveaway and leave it at that
right now cuz it's
it there there's a story but I now's not
the time to tell it um so will I ever do
an ultra po or orb po give
giveaway um maybe
so I really really really don't like
doing giveaways I feel like
it's it's it feels to me like it's
engagement farming like I I know that I
know that people like the idea of
getting uh Kevin no I'm afraid the link
did not come through if you want you can
email it to me Drex drexfactor dcom but
um YouTube is not letting you put
through the uh the link it doesn't look
like
um
so yeah I I feel I I doing giveaways
makes me feel a little bit icky because
I feel like I'm basically bribing people
to interact with me and I I I kind of
was just like nah if I have to bribe
people to to interact with my content
that I'm not making good content um all
that said I do recognize that it is
something people really like it people
like getting free props they they like
it's it's it's like gambling you know it
it it like it it punches a dopamine
button and I I do get that um amusingly
enough this is something Ultra poy
really really wants me to do and um when
I negotiated my 20124 contract with
them um this was something they
specifically asked me to do and I I I
just kept thinking to myself like yeah
I'll do that next month yeah I'll do
that next month I'll do and I just now
we're here at the end of 2024 and I
still haven't done done it um so they're
they're probably going to put the screws
to me to do it in 2025
so short answer is maybe
um I also just like I have a lot of
questions about how they're even done
because it's
like
um you know what form of Engagement are
are you judging the thing based on is it
like oh you know tagging a friend or
liking the post or what have you and
then how do you
um how do you then scrape that data and
then like select a winner I know that
the that there are solutions to these
problems that exist out there I just
haven't looked into them and and I I
keep giving myself this as an excuse not
to uh not to do it
um but yeah the long short of it is is
just it it feels kind of icky to me in a
lot of ways
um I will tell you though the the way I
thought to do this that makes sense in
my mind
cuz I feel like just doing a straight
ahead follow my channel to get free
is is again just kind of icky to me um
what I might do instead is like write up
a combo or a piece of choreography or
something like that and it's just like
yeah you know post your version of this
combo to get entered into uh and entered
into this giveaway because then I feel
like something of value would actually
be created out of
it but I don't know that might
uh i' I've tried doing things like that
before like there was a um there was a
piece of choreography I wrote earlier in
the year and I I specifically put it out
to people as like
hey if you if you learn this uh beginner
combo you can uh request a three-point
trick from me because people have been
requesting me to do threep videos now
for quite some time I had no takers at
all so there there's probably an element
to it where people are just kind of like
yay I get free for no effort
um I I would want to
have I could try something like that and
see how it's received um and then maybe
eventually find my way back to no I
guess I'll just you know get get get get
free Shi for tagging your friends and
and boosting my uh boosting my my stats
here kind of
thing uh yeah it's as as you can tell
it's it's not a thing that I I'm super
enthusiastic about but I'll give you a
solid maybe a solid maybe on that
one
um Charlie frier II asks which websites
can I order POI from for USA customer
customers such as myself because ignis
scamed me but fortunately I used my
credit card and managed to get my money
back well I'm I'm really sorry to hear
that um you had some challenges uh
dealing with
ignis it is always challenging when
you're dealing with uh an overseas
company okay so here's here's the big
challenge um there are currently no
us-based companies that make
programmable poy if that's what you're
looking for for reasons that are still
mysterious to me and goodness only knows
there's a there there's got to be a
video essay buried in this somewhere um
programmable po all come out of Eastern
European companies it's the damnest
thing um and no us-based companies have
have have picked them up um and I I'm
not sure entirely why that is I I think
that there's a hump to get over there in
terms of like research and development
and I I also think that um there's
probably some degree of of companies
kind of sticking clear of each other's
sandboxes a little bit so unfortunately
there's no answer for for uh buying
programmable poy that are made here in
the United States
um
if if you want to try buying some
programmable poy that so the best
experiences I've had with programmable
poyer definitely with pyro Tera light
toys they have a great interface the
editing program is Fant fantastic it's
it's super Sleek
um and I know the people that run the
company they're awesome people um they
uh they they will treat you right and
they will they have awesome customer
service you do have to deal with
shipping the POI back and forth across
the pond of course but
um such is life if you don't need your
poy to be programmable if you just need
them to have that form factor and
display some graphics there are the um
um the pop and flow poy from flow toys
um I have a set of them they're they're
they're pretty much the only set of like
and it's a pain in the ass because we
don't have a name for this class of
products and it's hard to give it a name
without running into somebody's
copyright because like I want to call
them graphic poy but that A1
Technologies already has that um that
that's that's a copyrighted a trademark
name that they have
um so I would just call them like
picture poy maybe um so the pop and flow
poy I think are pretty much the closest
thing you're going to get buying within
the United States
unfortunately if you're looking for
another type of product though you can
let me know um but that that those would
be my
recommendations oh
goodness we still got a lot of people in
the chat here
um Mark stof says hi from Bulgaria hello
from Washington
DC um I hope you have a nice and
successful 2025 me three I'm trying to
learn meltdowns I can wind up both ways
but I still have trouble switching from
one side all the way to the
other yes that is challenging um
especially because it works different
going one way than it does the other
all right so
meltdowns um
so I'm going to I'm going to teach this
assuming that your dominant direction of
spin is clockwise because that's my
dominant direction of spin in which
case you always start off your meltdowns
facing stage left the pois spinning
reverse you reach your left hand behind
your back your right hand is wrapped
around in front of your waist so it's
like you're wearing a belt made out of
your arms because that image is not
nightmare
Fuel and when you switch to the other
side you're going to wind up in a place
where it's now your right hand behind
your back and your left hand in front of
you once again you're putting together a
uh belt made of arms because yes I have
I just have more nightmare fuel for you
tonight hey um but this time the PO will
be spinning forwards
so the uh the easy way the easy
direction from this is going from
reverse to forwards why is that because
you just have to bring your left hand
out from behind you and take your right
hand out to the side so you basically
open up into an extension and then you
close back up with your right hand
reaching behind your back and your left
hand wrapping around in front of you um
so you could you could almost think of
this as being somewhat analogous to what
happens in a weave when you're doing
your waist straps going back and forth
from the reverse side your right hand
kind of takes off and then the left hand
follows it and the only difference here
is that when the right hand kind of
takes off here um rather than just kind
of stopping when it reaches over to the
right it continues going around as the
PO goes down and then as the PO comes
back up your arm wraps around behind you
like
so and then it just means that when your
left hand arrives over at your right
side it's crossing over to your right
hand side which honestly is what happens
with your left left hand when you're
doing a waist strap anyway your left
hand is still going all the way over to
wrap around and uh go across your
body so that part of it feels remarkably
like a waist strap it's the getting back
right so we have what feels like an
extension going this way and then we
have to come back and wrap everything
back up how exactly does that work well
the long and short of it is that um we
kind of have to keep our po tucked up
close to our body as we're going back so
for the left hand as it's crossed over
here we want to as it's coming down and
around bring it down as it comes up we
wrap it around behind our back so it's
two beats to get back we have one two to
get it behind your back
there um the right hand likewise it
takes two beats to get around so we have
the right hand one two and we have it
wrapped around uh in front of you to
create our belt of arms once again so
you want to think it's one beat to get
around one two beats to get back one
beat to get around one two beats to get
back you can open up going to forwards
you have to keep it kind of closed going
back to
reverse like so and then coming back and
um the motion that your arms are going
through as you're doing this is
literally just tracing their way across
your waist here so as I have my right
hand um next to my left hip here facing
over towards the right I trace it across
the small of my back and then across my
waist to get to my left hip but with my
right hand reaching in front of me
likewise left hands in front I reach
across the front of my waist and then
across the small of my my back to get it
back to my starting position
here and because of this we sometimes
classify waist straps as a kind of body
Tracer um it's there there's some
disagreement on it but um yeah it's it
it has a lot of body Tracer like
qualities for
sure I hope that was
helpful oh my God my voice is getting a
little ragged friends sorry about that
um Charlie frier III you're right it
does need a USA distributor I
agree um Mark stof also I'm having
trouble to understand the transition
when doing a behind the back waist strap
when going from one side to the other
any tips this is going to haunt me until
the day that I die
so I don't entirely know how to teach
behind the back waist drops and there's
a really specific reason for it and that
reason
is
I the way I got down behind the back
waist straps was I was living in New
York
City 16 years ago no uh 15 years ago
excuse me and I had bronchitis and I
would I I was like down with a fever of
like
102 and as I was sitting there in my
fever Haze I saw in my
head how to do behind the back waist
drops it just popped into my head as I
was sitting there in like a fever dream
and as soon as I was well enough I got
up and did it and it just
worked and because I didn't struggle
with it I don't know how to teach
[Laughter]
it it's one of those things that just
because it just happened for me and I
didn't like
normally the way I teach is I look for
areas where
um where I ran into trouble and I kind
of assume that other people run into
trouble in the same
place and
um teaching people how to get through
that is is is is how I teach and because
I didn't struggle with that one I I it
is still mysterious to me how to teach
it um I can try though I can try
um so here's the way that I I think of
it at least
um and that
is what I saw in my fever
dream
was as my hands are sitting here behind
my back and I reach out towards the
right they kind of swirl around each
other namely my right hand swirls around
my
left and then I take the back over to
the left side of my waist and I let my
left hand swirl around my
right so in my mind it's like
twist and
twist
twist and twist like
so and when you do that with the poy it
turns into a waist strap
I'm still not sure why but it
does so
um yeah that's not a very satisfying
answer right now what I can do is I can
show it to you from a whole bunch of
different
angles so this is from the front and
again notice how I'm swirling my woo
that turned into a five beat that was
not intentional I'm swirling my hands
around each other on either side of my
waist
here and then let me show it to you from
the back
the one and only thing that was
mysterious is that I kind of have to
untwist going back to the left if you
see where my right reaches under and
then I need to um reach it above and
then back around under by the time I get
to the left
here so right over right over right over
right over right over right over like
that and that's how you make the
donuts I hope that was
helpful oh my
God my throat is really killing me right
now I I'm going to have to uh probably
cut things off around 8 here because uh
my voice is uh is not having a good time
right now
um then now is the time Mulla and Cara
says I know everything about excuses I
fully understand I'm glad hear it Kevin
logger I'm really into the geometry
aspects of Po and
when woo something came loose in that
one um I'm really into the geometry
aspects of Po and wondering where you
started in learning possibly a book or a
certain po celebrity that I should look
into um I'm so I'm not sure specifically
what you're asking for in terms of the
geometry aspects um I will say
that something
that was instrumental to me in my own
Journey with POI was
um uh whatam my jig it um discovering uh
how to use trigonometry to model POI
patterns on on uh graphing
calculators which
um I actually wrote an entire paper on
how to model uh different po patterns
inside of Apple's built-in graphing
calculator for its software um which I
can I can I can link to that in the chat
because it sounds like that could be
helpful
um please
hold yeah here we go
2015 goodness the 10th anniversary of
this paper is coming up next year I am
old that's okay it just means I've had
time to do a lot of cool
stuff so I would check out that paper
cuz it goes pretty in depth in the
mathematics um and like uh you'll learn
a lot in there about how uh this is a
specific type of math that's called uh
roulettes um anti-spin flowers are what
we call uh epids and uh ins spin flowers
are
hypotrochoid
um so that'll guide you
through um how to
book says dizzy it's 72
Pages it is 72 Pages it is is it 72
Pages it's 70 71
Pages yeah it's long it's long but hey
it goes Super in depth um it goes Super
in depth it it will teach you how to
model everything from flowers to weaves
to caps um and even toids and body
tracers
too so everything is in that paper there
the there's a reason it's so long it is
it is quite detailed it is very very
detailed so hopefully that helps um
hopefully that
helps uh Mulan Cara no programmable
pixel po manufacturers in the US in
exchange you have the two dopest LED
manufacturers the above mentioned Ultra
Point flow toys I swap those if I could
I
mean well here's the thing both of those
companies do have European Distributors
now I think you you can purchase them
from
uh I don't remember the names of the
shops but there there are European shops
that stock both at this point if memory
serves so you can you can buy those in
Europe and and not and
and there are EU based Distributors for
them for sure oh my God
so I still got the window open for the
math paper in the background and I'm
just seeing like the little icons for
people reading the document like popping
up in the background as I'm talking to
you all that's that's that's
wonderful um yes I think it's exactly
that aspect that makes it difficult but
I think this is really helpful said Mark
stoff cool I'm glad to hear that was
helpful Vortex Cal hey addx not a
question just wanted to thank you for
all the instruction and content you're
welcome I'm not the best po spinner but
I'm much better thanks to you I'm glad
to hear it I'm not the best po spinner
either doesn't matter if you're the best
it only matters if it's fun for you
sounds like it is so you're doing it
right um Mark stoff again spot on what I
was asking about thanks so much you're
welcome I'm glad to hear that uh I'm
glad to hear that I I connected the dots
there Kevin logger says thank you and I
sent that link via your email excellent
I'll I'll look forward to reading
it mandolin car thank you so much you're
welcome Kevin logger says I'm excited to
read and dizzy is rolling her eyes at me
for and that that that that's that's
legit that's
legit uh dizzy has read that paper
before um I I think it's probably a
short list of people that have read all
71 pages but I appreciate you doing so
uh Diz dizzy is my girlfriend by the way
everybody so she's she's uh she's gotten
to read a bunch of stuff from me that
she probably regrets having ever seen at
this
point uh mandul and Cara fire toys
indeed sells popo however in the end it
is not cheaper than to order is from the
US only Advantage is the shipping time
which is significantly shorter of course
yeah no and I mean if you want to buy
podpoi that you're you're not going
to you you you can't find them for for a
lower price that's just the way that
works Mulan car says if you have a link
at hand for EU based Ultra po
distributor kind of drop it here I don't
know I'd have to do a little bit of
research there I'm I'm pretty sure
they've got a a distributor in Europe
I'm I'm I'm pretty sure but um I could
be wrong and yeah I just don't know the
name off the top of my head I'm
afraid but um we are now at 5 past the
hour and as uh you may or may not be
able to hear um my throat is definitely
uh ready for a break at at this point so
I'm going to go ahead and wind things
down if anybody has any last minute
super chats they want to send I'd
appreciate it but no pressure there um
seriously though thank you to both
Carrie and Dan for your super chats this
evening and thank you to each and every
one of you out there that asked a
question I appreciate you so much and
even just those who popped in to say
nice things I I I appreciate you one and
all never says toy all um get well soon
says Mandu lar thank you so much I
appreciate it I really appreciate
it um cool cool I'm going to go ahead
and wind us down then for the evening
there friends um I appreciate you all so
much uh and hopefully we will see each
other again in January and um my throat
will be in much much better shape when
that happens but for right now it is
time for me to get another cup of tea
grab some dinner
and uh start unwinding for the night
thank you all so much and uh I'll see
you I I'll I'll see you next month and
Kevin says thank you get well I
appreciate it thank you so much thank
you so much I I I'm I'm working on it
Britney says thank you you're welcome
Britney cool cool friends all right and
with that I'm going to take my leave um
happy holidays out there whatever
holidays you may be uh celebrating in
the course of the next month uh take
care of each other be kind to each other
and um oh yay thank you
Vortex
Vortex calm Vortex calm yeah for so on
on my screen it cuts off people's names
unfortunately on the super chat but
thank you so much Vortex comom and hey
if you want to sneak in one more
question before I wrap up for the
evening feel free to do so I appreciate
you
um but in the meantime I I will say uh I
appreciate you all so much and I'll be
seeing you again for um another Q&A in
January seems like people enjoy these uh
and I enjoy all of you out there I
appreciate you so much um yeah uh oh you
know what I can yay I can give you a
heart I just realize that uh I'm good
have a great night and weekend cool
thank you so much Vortex commom uh yeah
happy holidays everybody have yourselves
a good night
um Good Luck uh getting through the the
winter sols just here the the very very
very short days are always challenging
for me and I can imagine there are many
of you out there who have challenging
time with it too um and when I see you
next the days will be getting longer
Hallelujah so have a good night friends
and I'll talk to you in January peace
out